This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. More than a hundred years ago, a Danish man named Edgar Rubin created an image. It became so popular, you can still buy posters of it today. The image is known as Rubin's Ways. If you google it right now, you might see a black vase against a white background. But if you stare at it, another image suddenly jumps out. Not a vase, but two faces in profile, gazing at each other across a black background.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。一百多年前，一位名叫埃德加·鲁宾的丹麦人创作了一幅图像。它非常受欢迎，以至于你今天依然能买到它的海报。这幅图被称为“鲁宾的多义图”。如果你现在在谷歌上搜索它，你可能会看到白色背景衬托下的一个黑色花瓶。但如果你盯着它看，另一幅图像会突然跃入眼帘。不是花瓶，而是两个面部轮廓，隔着黑色背景相对而视。
Ruben wasn't an artist. He was a psychologist, and he was interested in how the mind deciphers visual cues. There are many versions of Rubensweiss, this one where you see either a duck or a rabbit, another where you see either a young girl or an old woman. The point is that it's either or. Your mind alternates between seeing one picture or the other, but not both. I've often tried to make myself see both the ways and the faces at the same time.
鲁宾不是艺术家。他是一位心理学家，他对心智如何解读视觉线索很感兴趣。“鲁宾多义图”有许多版本，比如这个能让你看到鸭子或兔子的版本，或者另一个能让你看到年轻女孩或老妇人的版本。关键在于，这是一个非此即彼的选择。你的大脑会在看到一张图片和看到另一张图片之间交替，但无法同时看到两张。我经常试图让自己同时看到花瓶和面孔。
It's really hard to do, but if I succeed, it's usually only for a moment. Then my mind snaps back into the groove of seeing either one picture or the other. Edgar Rubens' creation is a metaphor for our times. In so many ways, across so many domains, we are pulled toward either or thinking. Are the people around us friends or foes, sinners or saints, super heroes or super villains. What are we to make of the neighbor who brings us soup when we are sick, but also shares vile opinions on social media? The supportive friend who is a bully at work, the hated politician who passes a law that
这真的很难做到，但如果我成功了，通常也只能维持短短的一瞬间。然后我的大脑就会迅速退回到非此即彼的固有思维模式中。埃德加·鲁宾的创作是我们这个时代的隐喻。在许多方面，在许多领域，我们都被拉向了非此即彼的思维方式。我们周围的人是朋友还是敌人，是罪人还是圣人，是超级英雄还是超级大反派。我们该如何看待那个在我们生病时给我们送汤，却又在社交媒体上发表恶毒言论的邻居？那个在工作霸凌他人，却也是个支持朋友的人？那个通过了
we like. These contradictions can be especially difficult within closed relationships. When the people who mean the most to us are also the ones who hurt us deeply. This week on Hidden Brain, the story of a woman named Stephanie Callin and her complicated relationship with a friend named Kim.
我们喜欢的法案却备受讨厌的政治家？在亲密关系中，这些矛盾尤其难以处理。当那些对我们最重要的人，同时也是深深伤害我们的人时。本期的《隐藏的大脑》，将讲述一个名叫斯蒂芬妮·卡林的女人的故事，以及她与一个名叫金的朋友之间复杂的关系。
We explore what their unusual story reveals about a mental ability that allows us to see the world in all its complexity. A quick note if you're listening with small children. This episode includes discussions of addiction and a suicide attempt. In college, Stephanie Kellen always felt there were two Stephanie's inside her. One was a student who kept everything together. The only one who woke up for 8 a.m. classes as
我们探讨了她们不同寻常的故事揭示了一种怎样的心理能力，这种能力能让我们看到一个拥有全部复杂性的世界。温馨提示：如果您正带着幼童收听，本期节目包含关于毒瘾和自杀未遂的讨论。在大学里，斯蒂芬妮·凯伦总觉得她的内心有两个斯蒂芬妮。一个是把一切都打理得井井有条的学生。她是
a freshman. The only one on her dorm floor who didn't drink. The other Stephanie carried around several demons from her childhood. Her family had moved around a lot, living in ten different homes by the time she was 18. They were poor. For years, Stephanie says, she was abused by someone close. When she turned 21, she had a drink for the first time. And the Stephanie no one else could see burst into view.
大一新生中唯一一个能按时起床上早上8点课程的人。是她宿舍楼里唯一一个不喝酒的人。另一个斯蒂芬妮则背负着童年留下的几个恶魔。她的家庭经常搬家，在她18岁之前，已经在十个不同的地方住过。他们很穷。斯蒂芬妮说，多年来，她一直遭到身边某人的虐待。在她21岁那年，她生平第一次喝了酒。那个别人看不到的斯蒂芬妮猛然闯入了视线。
The first time that alcohol hit my lips, I was drinking alcoholically. I had no buildup, I had no, oh, I'm just gonna party, nope, it was drink to blackout from the get-go, from my 21st birthday. So I kept up the outer view of me where I was this straight-laced girl who never did anything wrong and got
酒精流进我嘴里的那一刻起，我的喝酒方式就是酗酒式的。我没有任何铺垫，我没有那种“哦，我只是去聚会”的想法，完全没有。从我的21岁生日开始，从一开始我就是喝到断片。所以我维持着外界对我的看法，我是一个循规蹈矩的女孩，从来不做错事，
straight A's and did everything right. For a while, she managed to juggle both lives. She wanted to be a piano teacher and she kept up with her schoolwork. When I could get to the point of the evening where I didn't have any homework left and I had done all of my piano practicing, I would drink an entire bottle of peppermint schnops, for example, and just black out and then get up for my 8am classes and push myself and push myself. And when I graduated from college, this was my pattern.
门门功课拿全A，每件事都做得对。有一段时间，她设法兼顾了这两种生活。她想成为一名钢琴老师，并且跟上了学业。每当熬到晚上没有作业，且完成了所有钢琴练习的时候，例如，我会喝掉整整一瓶薄荷甜酒，然后直接断片，接着又爬起来去上早晨8点钟的课，拼命逼自己，不断地逼自己。当我大学毕业时，这就是我的模式。
Stephanie graduated with high honors in 2001. She met a cute guy at a church singles group the next year, and soon they got married. She achieved her dream, landing a job as an elementary school music teacher. Her partner had a good job too. From the outside, their lives looked glamorous. We were having corporate dinners at our house and I was hosting these big elaborate dinner parties, but then of course would then drink a whole bottle of vodka when I was
斯蒂芬妮于2001年以优异的成绩毕业。第二年，她在教堂的单身聚会上遇到一个可爱的男生，不久他们就结婚了。她实现了自己的梦想，找到了一份小学音乐老师的工作。她的伴侣也有一份不错的工作。从外表上看，他们的生活光鲜亮丽。我们会在家里举办公司晚宴，我还会主持那些大型精致的晚宴，但当然，当我自己一个人的时候，
alone. The pattern continued for nearly seven years. Teach kids during the day, be the good corporate wife in the evening, drink until she blacked out at night. In January 2009, Stephanie's marriage collapsed. She felt like she didn't need to fake things anymore. When school led out for the summer, she started drinking around the clock. Wake up, drink, blacker. Repeat. And here I was 30 years old. Life had screwed me over. So my double life became one life. And it became my alcoholic life. And I didn't try to hide my pain anymore.
我就会偷偷喝掉一整瓶伏特加。这种模式持续了近七年。白天教孩子们，晚上做优秀的公司贤内助，夜里则喝酒直到断片。2009年1月，斯蒂芬妮的婚姻破裂了。她觉得没必要再伪装了。当学校放暑假时，她开始没日没夜地喝酒。醒来，喝酒，断片。周而复始。而当时我30岁。生活把我搞惨了。所以我的双重生活合二为一了。它变成了我的酗酒生活。我不再试图掩盖我的痛苦。
In her mind, there was good Stephanie and there was bad Stephanie. Good Stephanie taught kids music, worked hard. Bad Stephanie drank to blackout, abandoned her dreams. There was no one in between. One day in June 2009, she woke up from drinking all night and reached straight for her vodka. But... Something...
在她的脑海里，有好斯蒂芬妮，也有坏斯蒂芬妮。好斯蒂芬妮教孩子们音乐，工作努力。坏斯蒂芬妮酗酒断片，抛弃梦想。中间没有任何过渡。2009年6月的一天，她整晚喝酒后醒来，直接伸手去拿伏特加。但是……有些……
Though, made me stop. Instead of my vodka, I went to my computer. And I looked up AA. AA, of course, is alcoholics anonymous. The support group for people fighting alcohol addiction. Stephanie went to an AA meeting. When it was over, a woman walked up and introduced herself. For reasons that would become clear, we're only using her first name.
东西，让我停了下来。我没有去拿伏特加，而是走向电脑。我查了AA。AA，当然就是匿名戒酒互助会。这是一个为对抗酒精成瘾的人提供支持的组织。斯蒂芬妮去参加了一个AA会议。会议结束后，一个女人走过来做了自我介绍。出于将变得显而易见的原因，我们只使用她的名字。
Kim. She was just this bright, charismatic girl, 5, 10 blonde, gorgeous. One of those girls that would never have even given me the time of day in high school. She had a swagger, she had this air about her that made you feel like you could tell her anything. This confidence in her own self, but also this confidence in the other sense of the word that you could bring her into your confidence and tell her anything. Someone who would be your instant best friend. And she comes over to me and she gives me her phone number and says to me, call me. No matter what, whenever it is, day or night, call me.
金。她就是那种开朗、有个人魅力的女孩，身高一米七五，金发碧眼，美艳动人。就是那种在高中时甚至都不会正眼瞧我一眼的女孩。她走路趾高气昂，身上有一种气质，让你觉得什么话都可以对她说。她对自己充满自信，而且在另一个意义上也让人充满信任——你可以把秘密托付给她，告诉她任何事。她会立刻成为你无话不谈的闺蜜。她朝我走过来，把电话号码交给我，对我说：给我打电话。无论发生什么，无论什么时候，白天还是黑夜，给我打电话。
It was the first time anyone had ever seen the real me and still wanted to talk to me. Stephanie kept returning to AA meetings, partly because she wanted to see more of her new friend. Kim introduced Stephanie to other regulars. She checked in on her. A few weeks later, Stephanie was up late at night, her mind spinning in circles from not drinking.
这是第一次有人看到了真实的我，却依然想跟我说话。斯蒂芬妮不断重返AA会议，部分原因是为了能多见见这位新朋友。金把斯蒂芬妮介绍给了其他常客。她经常关心她。几个星期后，斯蒂芬妮深夜难眠，脑子里因为没有喝酒而思绪万千，翻江倒海。
She paced her apartment, chain smoking, wide awake. Suddenly she had a mad impulse. I'm an avid reader and I had three bookshelves full of books and here I am in my little apartment at midnight one in the morning and I find that in order to stay sober I have to Alphabetize my books right now. I Take all my books off myself and all my books are on my apartment living room floor And I start alphabetizing, but then I get one shelf in and I think wait Should I alphabetize it by title or by author last name? Oh my god. I
她在公寓里踱步，一根接一根地抽烟，毫无睡意。突然，她有了一个疯狂的冲动。我是一个狂热的阅读爱好者，我有三个书架的书，而现在我独自在这个午夜或凌晨一点的小公寓里，我发现为了保持清醒，我必须立刻把我的书按字母顺序重新排列。我把所有的书从书架上拿下来，所有的书都堆在我公寓的客厅地板上，然后我开始按字母顺序排列。但是排了一层书架后，我想，等等，我应该按书名排，还是按作者的姓氏排？哦，天哪。我
About two shelves in go. You know what I should call someone And I call Kim at two in the morning. She picks up. I tell her I'm going crazy. I'm alphabetizing my books and and she says, come on over. Stephanie drove the five minutes to Kim's house full of gratitude for her new friend. That night, I was trying to, you say, sober, sleep in on her couch. In the morning, she was like, hey, I'm looking for a roommate. And I was like, sure, this is the nicest anyone has treated me in my entire life. I'll move in with this girl.
差不多排了两层书架后心想：你知道吗，我应该给某人打个电话。于是我在凌晨两点给金打了电话。她接了。我告诉她我快疯了，我正在按字母顺序整理书。她却说：“过来吧。”斯蒂芬妮开车花了五分钟来到金的家，内心充满了对新朋友的感激。那天晚上，我在她家的沙发上，可以说是清醒着试着入睡。到了早上，她说：“嘿，我在找室友。”我当时就想：“好啊，这是我一生中遇到对我最好的人。我要搬去和这个女孩一起住。”
Stephanie prepared for the move. And she began spending more and more time with Kim. Over those next weeks, I started meeting other people. And would go to her house. She would have people over. She would have huge sober parties. And I would stay up all night at a 24-hour diner on Kohlfax in Denver called Pete's Kitchen
斯蒂芬妮为搬家做好了准备。她开始花越来越多时间和金在一起。在接下来的几周里，我开始结识其他人，并会去她家。她会举办聚会。她会举办大型的无酒精派对。我会和聚会上认识的人一起，在丹佛科尔法克斯街上一家名叫“皮特厨房”的24小时餐厅待上一整夜，
with people from the meetings. And we would just keep each other company to try to not drink. For Stephanie, the AA group was a lifeline, an oasis, and at the center of it was this new friend Kim who was there to pick her up whenever she stumbled. It was a really beautiful time of finding people and being real with people. At the same time, just not really being able to string together any more than a few days before I would go back to the bottle.
大家互相作伴，努力不去喝酒。对斯蒂芬妮来说，AA小组是一条生命线，是一片绿洲，而这一切的核心就是这位新朋友金。每当她跌倒时，金总会在那里拉她一把。那是一段非常美好的时光，大家结识彼此，以诚相待。与此同时，实际上却怎么也无法坚持清醒超过几天，然后就会再次拿起酒瓶。
Stephanie wasn't struggling just to remain sober. She was struggling with increasingly deep depression. A note that this next part of the story has to do with suicide. I had this belief that things weren't supposed to be good for me. Nothing would actually ever get good things weren't supposed to be good for me. Nothing would actually ever get good because nothing in my life ever was good. And I was convinced that death was the only option because I was never going to be able to have a happy life. One night, she was in her apartment alone.
斯蒂芬妮不仅在努力戒酒。她还在与日益严重的抑郁症作斗争。需要提醒的是，故事的下一部分涉及自杀。我当时有一种信念，认为事情本不该对我是好的。任何事情实际上永远都不会变好，事情本不该对我是好的，任何事情实际上永远都不会变好，因为我生活中的一切从来没有好过。我确信死亡是唯一的出路，因为我永远无法过上幸福的生活。一天晚上，她独自待在公寓里。
She had missed that day's AA meeting. I had Already drunk the handle of vodka and I had my pills ready And I said I don't see a way out. I don't see a way to have a happy life because it's all just gonna Become anyway And I don't see a way to have a happy life because it's all just gonna become anyway. And I don't see a way to escape the bad. That was when Kim called me. Miracle number one was that I actually picked up the phone and that she called me at that moment. And she called me at that moment and she called
她错过了当天的AA会议。我已经喝完了一整瓶伏特加，而且我的药也准备好了。我说，我看不到出路。我看不到过上幸福生活的方法，因为这一切无论如何都会……而且我看不到过上幸福生活的方法，因为这一切无论如何都会变成这样。而且我找不到逃离痛苦的方法。就在那时，金给我打了电话。第一个奇迹是我居然接了电话，而且她偏偏在那一刻给我打了电话。而且她偏偏在那一刻给我打电话，她打电话
me to see why I wasn't at that daily meeting. Miracle number two was that I was honest with her and I told her, I'm going to kill myself. And I don't remember what was going through my head except that I just didn't care anymore. Just didn't care. Couldn't see any way out, couldn't see which way to go. She didn't care. What happened to me? Didn't care who knew.
来是想看看我为什么没有去参加那个例会。第二个奇迹是我对她说了实话，我告诉她：“我要自杀。”我不记得当时脑子里在想什么，只记得我不在乎了。就是不在乎了。看不到任何出路，不知道该往哪个方向走。她不在乎。我遭遇了什么？不在乎谁会知道。
As soon as I said, well, I'm sitting here going to kill myself. She just said, oh, I'll be right over. When we come back, how can saved Stephanie's life? life. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Every day from the moment we wake up, our minds are interpreting the things we see, like Edgar Rubin's famous image and telling us, this is a vase, or these are two faces. So much of this happens outside of conscious awareness. We rarely stop and think about whether we are seeing a complete view of the world, if
我一说“好吧，我正坐在这里准备自杀”，她就说：“哦，我马上过来。”广告回来后，是什么拯救了斯蒂芬妮的生命？生命。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。每天从我们醒来的那一刻起，我们的大脑就在解读我们所看到的事物，比如埃德加·鲁宾著名的图像，并告诉我们：这是一个花瓶，或者这是两张脸。这一切绝大部分都发生在我们的意识之外。我们很少停下来思考，我们是否看到了一个完整的世界，我们
we are seeing things in all that complexity. Some people seem better than others at holding competing concepts in their heads. Psychologists call this integrative complexity. Can you see that Edgar Rubens' picture is not just a vase and it's not just two faces, but both at the same time? Our social groups often yank us away from integrative complexity. Our tribes often want us to see things as they see them. Take a hot button issue like abortion. Opponents of abortion say it's about the life
是否看到了事物复杂的全貌。有些人似乎比其他人更能将相互对立的概念同时装在脑子里。心理学家称之为综合思维能力。你能看出埃德加·鲁宾的画不仅仅是一个花瓶，也不仅仅是两张脸，而是两者同时存在吗？我们的社交圈子经常把我们从综合思维中拉开。我们的群体往往希望我们按照他们的视角来看待事物。以堕胎这样备受争议的议题为例。反堕胎人士说这关乎一个
of an unborn child. Supporters of abortion rights say the central issue is a woman's right to choose. One side says, ending a life is wrong. There's nothing else to talk about. The other side says, a woman's control over her own body is sacrosanct, there's nothing else to discuss. If you have strong views on the subject, but attempt to understand where the other side is coming from, chances are that the people on your side will come down on you like a ton of bricks. One reason integrated complexity is so hard, it might seem, sometimes even in our own
未出生孩子的生命。支持堕胎权的人则认为，核心问题是女性的选择权。一方说，结束一条生命是错误的。没有什么好讨论的。另一方说，女性对自己身体的控制权是不容侵犯的，没有什么好讨论的。如果你在这个问题上有强烈的观点，但试图去理解另一方的立场，那么很有可能你阵营里的人会对你口诛笔伐。综合思维之所以如此艰难的一个原因，在于有时甚至在我们自己的
minds, like this loyalty. At the point Stephanie Kellen tried to take her own life, there was only one way for her to see her friend Kim. She was an unambiguous force for good. When Stephanie told Kim what she was doing, Kim dropped everything and rushed over. The rest is a little bit foggy because I was already drunk. I remember her coming into my apartment. I don't know, it could have been two minutes later, could have been 15 minutes later. I remember her walking kind of like as if in a dream, her walking me down to her car,
心智中，它看起来像是某种不忠诚。在斯蒂芬妮·凯伦试图结束自己生命的那一刻，她只能用一种方式来看待她的朋友金。金是纯粹的、无可争议的善良力量。当斯蒂芬妮告诉金她正在做什么时，金放下手头的一切，匆忙赶了过来。接下来的事情有点模糊，因为我当时已经喝醉了。我记得她走进我的公寓。我不知道，可能是两分钟后，也可能是15分钟后。我只记得她走起路来像是在梦游一样，她扶着我走到她的车前，
putting me in her car, driving me to the hospital to the emergency room. She tried to get me to fill out the information, but I didn't care. I just didn't care. I put, I was put on a 72 hour suicide hold in their psych unit and they put me to bed. It was the most horrible, but also the most freeing moment of my entire life. All of my pretenses were gone. I just let go. I found out later that I had been going through alcoholic seizures. I found out later that I had been going through alcoholic seizures. It was as if I was in water and I was just surfacing every now and then surfacing. And that's how I lived for three days, Stephanie entered long-term care in the hospital.
把我塞进车里，开车把我送到医院的急诊室。她试图让我去填写信息，但我不在乎。我真的不在乎。我被送进了他们精神科病房，进行为期72小时的自杀监视，他们让我躺在床上。那是我一生中最可怕、但也是最解脱的时刻。我所有的伪装都消失了。我彻底释怀了。我后来才知道，我当时一直在经历酒精戒断性癫痫发作。我后来才知道，我当时一直在经历酒精戒断性癫痫发作。就好像我在水里一样，我只是时不时地浮出水面，浮出水面。这就是我那三天过日子Etat的方式，斯蒂芬妮进入了医院的长期护理。
She started the path to recovery. She still remembers the moment when she finally surfaced for good. I was sitting in our group and outside the window, the sun was setting. And it was shining right in my eye. And it just was that moment of, I don't want to miss this beautiful world and then followed by, wow, that girl saved my life. Followed by, I need to get sober, you know, just like one after another, just boom, boom. It came around to my time to share, and I just remember saying, guys, I want to live, and the room just erupted in tearing. And I was like, yes, you did it.
她踏上了康复之路。她依然记得自己最终彻底浮出水面的那一刻。我坐在小组里，窗外太阳正在落山。夕阳正好照在我的眼睛上。那一刻的感觉是，我不想错过这个美好的世界，紧接着的念头是：哇，那个女孩救了我的命。接着是：我需要戒酒，你知道的，一个接一个，就像连珠炮一样，轰，轰。轮到我分享的时候，我只记得我说过：“伙计们，我想活下去。”房间里顿时爆发出泪水和欢呼。我当时想：是的，你做到了。
And it was amazing. I'll never forget it. Kim didn't just save her life. She helped to run Stephanie's life while she was in the hospital. While I was in the suicide hold and the two weeks in the psych ward, I didn't have my phone or my wallet or any of that because they want you, of course, to be disconnected from the outside world in order to focus on recovery.
那真是太神奇了。我永远不会忘记。金不仅仅救了她的命。在斯蒂芬妮住院期间，她还帮她打理生活。在我接受自杀监视和在精神病房度过的两周里，我没有手机、钱包或任何这些东西，因为当然了，他们希望你与外界隔绝，以便专注于康复。
So she took care of all of that for me. At that time, I was still paying bills through check. So she took my checkbook and I would sign a few checks and she would pay my bills for me. She didn't have a car of her own. So she drove my car while I was in the hospital, but would fill it with gas, and she would wash it and make sure that it was already for me when I got out. I needed to put some of my things in storage, so she took care of a storage unit. So I had all this jewelry and my wedding ring
所以她替我处理了所有这些事情。那时候，我还在用支票支付账单。所以她拿着我的支票簿，我签了几张支票，她就帮我付了账单。她自己没有车。所以我在医院期间，她开着我的车，但她会给车加满油，还会把它洗干净，确保我出院时车已经准备好了。我需要把一些东西存放在仓库里，所以她处理了一个储物单元。所以我当时所有的珠宝和我离婚时的结婚戒指都在里面。
from my divorce at that time. And yeah, I just went above and beyond. When Stephanie got out of the hospital, her lease on her apartment was about to end. Kim invited her to move in. I was, yes, of course, I'll move in with you. And all I had to do was just basically drive over to my new apartment with her. But I mean, at this point, this is somebody who is playing more than a role of a friend. I mean, she comes over, saves your life, takes you to the ER, looks after your affairs, pays your bill, pays your rent, looks after your car, gets you to sort of sign a lease moving into her place, moves your stuff into storage, essentially have you come over. I mean, at this point, she's almost apparent to you.
是的，她做得远远超出了职责范围。当斯蒂芬妮出院时，她公寓的租约快到期了。金邀请她搬过去住。我当时想，好啊，当然，我搬去和你一起住。我所要做的基本上就是和她一起开车去我的新公寓。但我的意思是，到了这个时候，这个人扮演的角色已经远超一个朋友了。我的意思是，她过来救了你的命，带你去急诊室，照顾你的事务，付你的账单，付你的房租，照顾你的车，让你签了搬进她家的租约，把你的东西搬进仓库，基本上就是让你搬过去。我的意思是，在这个时候，她几乎就像你的父母。
Oh, she was everything. As she was a pseudo-parent, is the right word for it, I was nothing but grateful to her, obliged to her kind of dependent upon her, anything that she needed, it was yes. Stephanie trusted Kim in a way she had never done with another human being. I would still have those sleepless nights where I would kind of just be out of my mind I would kind of just be out of my mind with wanting to drink and one night we sat on our front porch smoking away into the night. And as we smoked cigarettes out there, she started asking me about my past. And I found myself telling her things I'd never told anyone in my entire life. Stephanie shared details about her troubled childhood and the trauma of living in poverty and being abused.
哦，她就是一切。如果说她是我的“类父母”，这词用得挺贴切的话，我对她只有感激、亏欠，某种程度上还依赖她，她需要什么，我的回答都是“好”。斯蒂芬妮对金的信任是她对其他任何人类从未有过的。我依然会有那些不眠之夜，有时我会急得发疯，那种想喝酒的欲望折磨得我快要发疯，一天晚上，我们坐在前廊上抽烟抽到深夜。当我们在那里抽烟时，她开始问起我的过去。我发现自己竟然把从未对世界上任何人讲过的事告诉了她。斯蒂芬妮分享了她动荡的童年、生活在贫困中以及遭受虐待的创伤等细节。
She told me about when someone does a bad thing, shame is created. And she said, think of shame as a black ball. And somebody has to hold that black ball. And often it's the victims who end up holding that black ball. Kim told Stephanie that the ball of shame she was carrying around wasn't hers to hold any longer. I cried and we hugged and I felt listened to for the first time. As Winter turned to spring, the two women grew closer and closer. Stephanie had gone back to work after getting out of the hospital and staying with Kim helped
她告诉我，当一个人做了坏事时，羞耻感就产生了。她说，把羞耻感想象成一个黑色的球。必须有人来拿着这个黑色球。通常最后拿着这个黑色球的都是受害者。金告诉斯蒂芬妮，她一直带着的那个羞耻之球不该再由她来承担了。我哭了，我们拥抱了，我第一次觉得自己被倾听了。随着冬天变成春天，两个女人越来越亲密。斯蒂芬妮出院后重新开始工作，和金住在一起有助于
keep her sober. At one point, Kim asked Stephanie for a $4,000 loan. Stephanie had alimony from her divorce and lent Kim the money. It felt like the least she could do. In April 2010, Stephanie relapsed. She went back to rehab this time for four months. Kim took care of her affairs while she was away, as before. When Stephanie left rehab, Kim had moved into a new apartment.
帮她保持清醒。有一次，金向斯蒂芬妮借4000美元。斯蒂芬妮有离婚后的赡养费，于是把钱借给了金。这感觉像是她力所能及最小的事了。2010年4月，斯蒂芬妮复吸了。她再次回到戒毒所，这一次待了四个月。在她离开期间，金和以前一样帮她打理事务。当斯蒂芬妮离开戒毒所时，金已经搬进了一套新公寓。
She invited Stephanie to join her again. But I had decided that I needed to try things on my own. And you know, she supported that. The rehab program sets Stephanie up with a furnished apartment. She moved in at the end of September 2010. So I moved into my, for the very first time, my very own apartment, sober, feeling great, paying all my bills, going to work, living a sober life, feeling peaceful, feeling happy. A week or so later, Stephanie invited Kim over. They both had things to celebrate. Stephanie was on the right track with her sobriety, and Kim had finished her studies to become
她邀请斯蒂芬妮再次和她一起住。但我决定我需要独自尝试一下生活。你知道的，她对此表示支持。戒毒所项目为斯蒂芬妮安排了一间带家具的公寓。她于2010年9月底搬了进去。于是我搬进了我的，生平第一次，真正属于我自己的公寓，保持着清醒，感觉好极了，支付所有的账单，去上班，过着清醒的生活，感到平静，感到快乐。大约一周后，斯蒂芬妮邀请金过来。她们都有值得庆祝的事。斯蒂芬妮的戒酒进展顺利，而金也完成了学业，成为了一名
a certified addictions counselor. When Kim arrived at the door of the building, she called up to Stephanie to look out the window of the apartment. So I go over and I look out the window and I look down. And there she is on the curb in front of my apartment building with this brand new dodge. She had been driving beaters and then they had died and then she wasn't driving and she was just walking and she's like, I got a new car.
注册成瘾咨询师。当金到达大楼门口时，她打电话让斯蒂芬妮看公寓的窗户。于是我走过去，看向窗外，向下望去。她就站在我公寓楼前的路边，开着一辆崭新的道奇汽车。她以前一直开破车，后来车彻底报废了，然后她就没车开只能步行，而现在她说：“我买新车了。”
And at that point, she had started working at a rehab. She was doing really good, you know, salary-wise. And here I was, sober and in my own place, and everything was great, and it was just thrilling, and we were so excited for each other, and that night was wonderful. A short while later, Kim returned the favor. She invited Stephanie over to her place. Her new place was this gorgeous penthouse apartment in this really upscale place. And I walk into her new apartment and there's all my stuff.
那时，她开始在一家戒毒所工作。她的薪水情况真的很好，你知道的。而我呢，保持着清醒，住在我自己的地方，一切都很好，简直太令人兴奋了，我们为彼此感到高兴，那天晚上非常美妙。不久之后，金投桃报李。她邀请斯蒂芬妮去她家。她的新家是位于一个非常高档小区的豪华顶层公寓。我走进她的新公寓，里面居然全都是我的东西。
My couch, my coffee table, my dishes, my silverware, all the stuff that she had said had been in storage. I said, oh, that's my couch. And she said, oh, the storage unit just got too expensive. I decided to sell my couch and just use yours. You had a nicer couch than I did anyway. And then I kind of laughed it off and then she served me dinner and I remember just laughing, oh wow, these are my plates. And she goes, I know they aren't they nice and we just had a good laugh about it. At one point in the evening, Stephanie told Kim she needed to use the bathroom. It was an apartment where the only bathroom was through her bedroom, so then she's shown me to the bathroom. And I look on her dresser and there's my jewelry box. This was jewelry that she had She had been keeping safe for me since my first hospitalization in July 2009.
我的沙发，我的茶几，我的盘子，我的银器，所有那些她说过放在仓库里的东西。我说：“哦，那是我的沙发。”她说：“哦，仓库的租金太贵了。我决定卖掉我的沙发，直接用你的。反正你的沙发比我的好看。”然后我笑了笑，接着她端上了晚饭，我记得自己当时笑着说：“哦，天哪，这些是我的盘子。”她说：“我知道，它们不是很漂亮吗？”我们对此开怀大笑。傍晚的时候，斯蒂芬妮告诉金她要用一下洗手间。那是一套唯一的洗手间必须穿过卧室才能进去的公寓，于是她带我去洗手间。我看了看她的梳妆台，那里放着我的首饰盒。这些首饰是她
I hadn't questioned what she had done with that jewelry where I had gone. I just trusted that it was safe. And it was at that moment that something started niggling at me. When Stephanie went back into the kitchen, she played it cool. I go, oh yeah, by the way, can I get that jewelry back? And she tells me, oh yeah, it's in the safety deposit box. I'll get it back to you as soon as I can.
自2009年7我第一次住院以来一直为我妥善保管的首饰。我从没有质疑过她把这些首饰放在了哪里，我只是坚信它们是安全的。就在那一刻，有什么东西开始在我的心头挥之不去。斯蒂芬妮回到厨房后，表现得很镇定。我说：“哦，对了，能把那些首饰还给我吗？”她告诉我：“哦，对，它们在保险箱里。我一有空就还给你。”
When we come back, Stephanie has to decide if the friend she knows and loves might also be a thief. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. There are times in our lives when seeing the world in black and white is essential. When you're drowning and someone throws you a lifeline, you don't stop to assess your rescuer's motives. You grab onto the rope. For more than a year, Kim had been Stephanie Kellyn's rescuer. She helps Stephanie stay sober and to peel back the layers of trauma that she had experienced. She was a pseudo parent and a one woman support system. When Stephanie was in crisis, there was only one Kim that she could see.
广告回来后，斯蒂芬妮必须决定，她了解并热爱的朋友是否也可能是一个小偷。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在我们的一生中，有时用非黑即白的视角看世界是至关重要的。当你溺水时，有人向你抛出救生索，你不会停下来评估拯救者的动机。你会紧紧抓住那根绳子。一年多来，金一直是斯蒂芬妮·凯伦的救星。她帮助斯蒂芬妮保持清醒，并剥开她曾经历过的层层创伤。她是类父母，也是一个人的支持系统。当斯蒂芬妮处于危机中时，她只能看到一个金。
Kim, the Savior. But when she went to Kim's apartment and saw that her friend was using all her things, she realized they might be another sight to him. Stephanie felt uneasy but tried to push away her concerns. She wanted to buy Kim's story of how Stephanie's couch and dinner plates ended up in Kim's penthouse apartment. There had to be some innocent explanation for why Stephanie's jewelry box had ended up in Kim's penthouse apartment. There had to be some innocent explanation for why Stephanie's jewelry box had ended up in Kim's bedroom.
那个救世主金。但是当她去金的公寓，看到朋友在使用她所有的东西时，她意识到金可能还有另一面。斯蒂芬妮感到不安，但试图把这种担忧压下去。她想要相信金关于斯蒂芬妮的沙发和餐盘是如何出现在金的顶层公寓里的那种说法。斯蒂芬妮的首饰盒怎么会出现在金的卧室里，这背后一定有什么无辜的解释。
A day or two later, Stephanie fired up her computer and checked her bank account. Kim had access to all her financial information. And I look in my bank account and it's gone, the $20,000. All of my Alamoney checks that I'd been receiving for the last year, gone. My checking account was at zero.
一两天后，斯蒂芬妮打开电脑，查看了她的银行账户。金拥有她所有的财务信息权限。我查看了我的银行账户，钱没了，那两万美元都没了。我过去一年收到的所有赡养费支票都没了。我的支票账户余额为零。
I just dumbfounded. What the heck, where is my money? Her first thought, someone at her bank had made a mistake. I go into the bank and I tell them, what is going on? Where's my money? And the lady said, it was all withdrawn by you. These checks were all signed by you. It's all legitimate. And I tell her, this wasn't me. The banker goes, have you checked your credit?
我当时直接惊呆了。搞什么鬼，我的钱去哪儿了？她的第一反应是，银行里的人搞错了。我走进银行告诉他们：“这到底是怎么回事？我的钱呢？”那位女士说：“这些都是你取走的。这些支票都是你签名的。一切都合规。”我告诉她：“这不是我干的。”银行职员问：“你查过信用记录吗？”
Which is not something I'd ever thought of. I look on my credit. The first thing I notice is that there's my name at the top of the list with Kim's new address under my name. Then the next item is a credit check from that upscale apartment requesting my credit, not Kim's credit, but Stephanie's credit check for that apartment. Next item is a car loan for the same making model of car that Kim had just shown me not two days before as her new car. What went through your head at that point, Stephanie, as you started, as the pieces started to fall together, I mean, what described that moment of epiphany for me?
这不是我以前想过的事情。我查看了我的信用记录。我注意到的第一件事是，列表最顶部是我的名字，而我名字下面写着金的新地址。接着下一项是那套高档公寓对我的信用查询——不是查询金的信用，而是查询斯蒂芬妮在这套公寓的信用。再下一项是一笔汽车贷款，正是金两天前向我展示的那款新车的品牌和型号。斯蒂芬妮，当这一切开始发生，当这些碎片开始拼凑在一起时，你脑子里在想什么？描述一下你当时的顿悟时刻吧。
disbelief, just utter like absolute surrealism. Like this feeling, like, I am no longer in my life, I am in a movie. They're gonna jump out and say, candid camera at any minute now. This is not what happens. You know, people don't save your life and then steal your identity. This isn't possible.
不相信，简直是彻底的、绝对的超现实主义。这种感觉就像：我不再过我自己的生活了，我是在拍电影。随时会有人跳出来大喊“隐藏的摄像机”。这种事不会发生。你知道的，人们不会先救了你的命，然后又偷走你的身份。这不可能。
This isn't possible. This is impossible. Stephanie's mind was fighting to keep the new picture of Kim at Bay. She wanted to hold on to the picture she loved. The Kim who answered her calls in the middle of the night. Who checked up on her when she didn't show up at AA meetings. The Kim, who literally swooped in and saved her life. This other Kim, no, she didn't want to see her. But like that image created by Edgar Rubin, the other Kim kept popping up. It was there in her bank statements, the credit reports, the car loan in black and white.
这不可能。这绝无可能。斯蒂芬妮的大脑在拼命抗拒关于金的新形象。她想要抓住她所热爱的那个形象不放。那个在半夜接听她电话的金。那个在她没有去AA会议时关心她的金。那个字面意义上从天而降救了她命的金。另一个金——不，她不想看到她。但就像埃德加·鲁宾创作的那幅图像一样，另一个金不断地浮现出来。它黑纸白字地写在她的银行对账单、信用报告和汽车贷款上。
So I called her, I called Kim that same day. She picked up and I say, what's going on, Kim? She immediately said something about, oh my goodness, yeah, let's talk about this, but I'm stepping into something, I gotta let you go and hung up. For the next few days, the two pictures of Kim battled for dominance inside Stephanie's head. She wanted to believe the best about her friend, but she also wanted to face the facts. So when she didn't hear back from Kim, she emailed her very politely to say that they needed to talk. Stephanie read the email for us, and we had a voice actor read Kim's response. Monday, October 11, 2010, at 8.24am. Kim, I understand that you would be hesitant to meet with me to discuss everything.
所以我给她打了电话，我当天就给金打了电话。她接了电话，我说：“金，这到底是怎么回事？”她立刻支支吾吾地说：“哦天哪，是的，我们谈谈这个，但我现在正要进到一个地方，我得挂了”，然后就挂断了电话。在接下来的几天里，金的这两种形象在斯蒂芬妮的脑海里争夺主导地位。她想对朋友抱最好的期望，但她也想面对现实。所以当她没有收到金的回复时，她非常礼貌地发邮件说她们需要谈谈。斯蒂芬妮为我们宣读了这封邮件，我们请了一位配音演员来宣读金的回应。2010年10月11日星期一，上午8点24分。金，我理解你可能对见面讨论这一切有所顾虑。
This situation needs to reach a resolution soon. Monday, October 11, 2010, 8.40 a. Stephanie. I can only guess how upset you are, and I'm prepared to do what it takes to take care of this the best I can. Monday, October 11, 2010, 3.35pm. Kim, I sent this to you in a text, but also wanted to elaborate in email. My biggest concern right now is the apparent lack of honesty and the feeling of not being able to trust anything. Please send me a text, email or phone call, with a time and place for Wednesday and I will be happy to meet you there. Thank you, Stephanie.
这种情况需要尽快得到解决。2010年10月11日星期一，上午8点40分。斯蒂芬妮。我完全能猜到你有多生气，我已经准备好尽我所能来妥善处理这件事。2010年10月11日星期一，下午3点35分。金，我在短信里也发过这个，但还是想在邮件里详细说明一下。我目前最大的担忧是明显的缺乏诚实，以及觉得什么都无法信任的感觉。请给我发个短信、邮件或打电话，告诉我周三的时间和地点，我很高兴在那里与你见面。谢谢，斯蒂芬妮。
Kim didn't write back. In Stephanie's mind, the picture of the Kim who had stolen her identity was now becoming easier to see than the Kim who had saved her life. That night, Stephanie sat outside on her balcony. She smoked, laid into the night, just like she had done with Kim countless times. I actually sat there thinking of human nature. Not necessarily of Kim, but of people. And I thought of some of the things I had done while I was drinking that I wasn't proud of.
金没有回信。在斯蒂芬妮的脑海里，那个偷走她身份的金的形象，现在比那个救了她命的金的形象更容易看清了。那天晚上，斯蒂芬妮独自坐在阳台上。她抽着烟，深夜久久不能入眠，就像她以前无数次和金一起做的那样。我实际上坐在那里思考人性。不一定是在想金，而是在想人。我回想起我喝酒时做过的一些自己并不以此为傲的事情。
Some of the ways I could have hurt people, some of the ways I did hurt people, and how I was trying to be a better person. And I thought of how we as humans can have equal capacity for harm and good. And this was the epiphany I had. The harm didn't negate the good, but the good did not excuse the harm. I realized that I could hold both. Humans can do immense harm to each other, and humans can do immense good to each other. She saved my life, and that was unarguable, but it didn't give her the right to then steal my identity and my money and my possessions. And at the same time, she stole my identity, but that didn't take away the good that she had saved my life.
我想到了我可能伤害过别人的一些方式，我确实伤害过别人的一些方式，以及我是如何努力做一个更好的人的。我想到我们作为人类，可以对伤害和善良具有同等的承受能力。这就是我顿悟到的时刻。伤害并没有否定善良，但善良也不能成为伤害的借口。我意识到我可以同时容纳这两者。人类可以对彼此造成巨大的伤害，人类也可以对彼此施予巨大的善意。她救了我的命，这是无可争辩的，但这并不赋予她随后偷走我的身份、我的金钱和我的财物的权利。与此同时，她偷走了我的身份，但这并没有抹杀她曾救过我性命的善良。
Seeing the world through the lens of integrative complexity is hard. Many people fear it will make them indecisive. But that was not Stephanie's experience. Being able to see the different sides of Kim, being able to see them simultaneously unparallized her. It had taken an act of will to see both sides of her friend, but when she did, she was impelled to take action. She called the police. Now, emotionally, there was still a part of her that recoiled against doing this, that sought to snap her back into seeing Kim one dimensionally. I felt like I was betraying her after all she had done for me. I was doing this. And here I was telling the police and the courts and everybody, these bad things that had happened in my life. And something in my gut
通过综合思维的镜头来看待世界是很艰难的。许多人担心这会让他们变得优柔寡断。但斯蒂芬妮的经历并非如此。能够看到金的不同面，能够同时看到它们，并没有让她陷入瘫痪。看到朋友的两面需要付出意志力，但当她做到这一点时，她被驱使着采取了行动。她报了警。现在，在情感上，仍然有一部分人在抗拒这样做，试图让她退回到单维度地看待金。我觉得自己背叛了她，毕竟她为我做了那么多。我居然在做这件事。而现在我却在告诉警察、法庭和所有人，这些发生在我生活中的坏事。我内心的某个地方
was telling me, this is wrong, you shouldn't be doing this. But at that time, I also had that other side of me to say, yes, you should be doing this. It's okay. You shouldn't be treated this way. It's okay to move on. It's okay to tell people what's happening. It's okay to demand that you be treated better. And that's what propelled me forward. After that, things moved quickly. Stephanie visited the bank and the apartment complex where Kim had used her name for a credit check. She told them Kim had stolen her identity. Soon after, the police repossessed Kim's new car.
在对我说：“这是不对的，你不应该这样做。”但在那时，我内心也有另一面在对我说：“是的，你应该这么做。这没关系。你不应该受到这样的对待。继续前进是没关系的。把发生的事情告诉别人是没关系的。要求自己受到更好的对待是没关系的。”正是这种想法推动我向前迈进。在那之后，事情进展很快。斯蒂芬妮去了银行以及金曾用她的名字进行信用查询的那个公寓大楼。她告诉他们金偷了她的身份。不久之后，警方扣押了金的新车。
Finally, Kim emailed her. It was a long message and we've pulled excerpts from it. Friday, October 15, 2010, 4.07am. Stephanie. This is possibly one of the hardest letters I have ever had to write. Please know that it was never my intention to hurt you. At first, I was only paying the bills you would ask me to pay, and using your card for shipping costs to send you things.
最后，金给她发了一封电子邮件。这是一封很长的信，我们摘取了其中的片段。2010年10月15日星期一，凌晨4点07分。斯蒂芬妮。这可能是我写过的最艰难的信之一。请相信，我从来没有想过要伤害你。起初，我只是支付你让我支付的账单，并使用你的卡支付运费来给你寄东西。
Quickly, however, it turned into using the card to take care of things I thought I needed to take care of for myself. As I look back on it now, it was stealing, no matter what I thought at the time. When I started to look for a new place to live, I found quickly that due to my bad financial decisions in the past, I didn't have the credit to get an apartment on my own, so I put you on the application as a cosigner. When the car I had broke down, I again used your credit to acquire a loan on a new car, thinking I would make the payments on it until I could just pay it off and full.
然而，很快它就演变成了使用这张卡来处理我认为我需要为自己处理的事情。现在回想起来，无论我当时怎么想，这就是偷窃。当我开始寻找新住处时，我很快发现由于过去糟糕的财务决策，我没有信用独自租下一套公寓，所以我在申请表上将你列为共同签署人。当我开的车坏了时，我又用你的信用申请了一笔新车贷款，心想我会一直还贷，直到我可以全额还清为止。
I don't really know what I was thinking. My dishonesty in these matters to myself and others is beyond comprehension. I didn't think about how I might hurt you, I just kept justifying or lying about how I just needed help for a little bit, and this was the only way I could get it. I know that forgiveness is out of the question, and that is not what I am expecting here. I hope you know that I am trying to mend the damage I have done. I am very scared, but prepared to take full responsibility where I need to. We reached out to Kim and left phone and social media messages seeking an interview, but she never responded. In the end, she was arrested and charged with theft, forgery and identity theft.
我真的不知道当时自己在想什么。我对这些事情对自己和他人的不诚实简直令人匪夷所思。我没有考虑这会如何伤害你，我只是不断地为自己辩解或撒谎，说我只是需要一点帮助，而这是我能获得帮助的唯一途径。我知道原谅是不可能的，我也没奢望在这里得到原谅。我希望你知道，我正在努力弥补我造成的损害。我非常害怕，但也准备好在需要的地方承担全部责任。我们联系了金，留下了电话和社交媒体信息寻求采访，但她从未回应。最后，她被捕并被控盗窃罪、伪造罪和身份盗窃罪。
She pleaded guilty to the charge of theft. Seven months later, Stephanie was invited to appear at Kim's sentencing. It was May 2011. The courthouse was on the same street as a bar where Stephanie used to drink until she blacked out, and the same street as the diner, where she would often grab a late-night snack with Kim in an effort to stay sober. Stephanie sat on the hardwood bench in the back row of the courtroom. The giant set of double doors opened. Kim walked in. There was Kim, I hadn't seen her in over a year.
她对盗窃指控认罪。七个月后，斯蒂芬妮应邀出庭参加对金的宣判。那是2011年5月。法院就在斯蒂芬妮过去常常酗酒到断片的酒吧同一条街上，也是她为了保持清醒而经常和金一起吃夜宵的小吃店同一条街上。斯蒂芬妮坐在法庭最后一排的硬木长椅上。巨大的双扇门打开了。金走了进来。金就站在那里，我已经有一年多没见她了。
She wouldn't meet my eye and she was standing with kind of her head down in her shoulders, hunched. And the glamour that I'd seen and the charisma that by this time it was, it had been two years since I had first met her. And there she was, she was just a broken person. The judge looks at me. She told me, you will be awarded compensation of $21,000 for the cash that she stole from your bank account.
她不敢看我的眼睛，她站着的时候有点把头埋在肩膀里，驼着背。而我曾经看到过的光芒和魅力，到这个时候——距离我第一次见到她已经过去两年了。她就站在那里，只是一个破碎的人。法官看着我。她告诉我：“你将获得21,000美元的赔偿金，以补偿她从你的银行账户中盗取的现金。”
Is there anything else you would like compensated? I felt a roar of anger and hurt about how this woman had treated me, and at the same time, that roar of anger was calmed by a feeling of utter peace. And standing there in the box, all of a sudden all this, all these feelings just ward up the anger, but the compassion and the peace and the resentment all at once. And my heart just melted because
你还有什么其他的赔偿要求吗？我感到内心涌起一股对这个女人如何对待我的愤怒与伤痛，与此同时，那股愤怒又被一种全然的平静感所抚平。就站在被告席上，突然间这一切，所有这些情绪都涌了上来——愤怒，但同时也有同情、平静和怨恨。我的心一下子融化了，因为
had I had her life, I cannot say that I would have acted differently. I cannot say that had I been through the trauma that she had been through, I wouldn't have treated people that way because I don't know. I had been through my trauma and I had made my choices that were caused by the trauma I had endured and what trauma had she endured? What trauma had she endured? And that was how when the judge looked at me and said, is there anything else you want to say to Kim?
如果我经历了她的人生，我不敢说自己会做得更好。我不敢说，如果我经历过她所经历的创伤，我就不会那样对待别人，因为我不知道。我也经历过自己的创伤，并做出了由我所承受的创伤所导致的决定，而她又承受了什么创伤呢？她究竟承受了什么创伤？正因如此，当法官看着我并问我，你还有什么话想对金说吗？
I found myself saying I only hope that she can find peace. And that was 10 years ago and I've had peace about her this whole time, if never felt any resentment or bitterness or I've been saved from wanting revenge. I've been saved from wanting revenge. I've been saved from harboring that bitterness for her and toward her. And I just feel peace. And that's all.
我发现自己说的是，我只希望她能找到平静。那是10年前的事了，这十年来我对她一直都很平静，从未感到过任何怨恨或苦涩，我也免于去渴望复仇。我免于去渴望复仇。我免于在心中对她怀揣这种苦涩。我只感到平静。这就是全部。
Kim was ordered to pay restitution and given three years probation, but she ended up violating the probation and spent some time behind bars. After the sentencing, Stephanie was able to find a new AA mentor and she met her now husband. They've been together for ten years and have two children together. She's been sober that whole time. She's been sober that whole time. At a time when social media and our political climate push us to see people and issues in black and white terms as enemies or allies, integrative complexity invites us to take a more
法院下令金进行赔偿并获得三年缓刑，但她最终违反了缓刑规定并在铁窗后度过了一段时间。宣判后，斯蒂芬妮找到了一位新的戒酒互助会导师，并遇到了她现在的丈夫。他们已经在一起十年了，育有两个孩子。她那段时间一直在戒酒。她那段时间一直在戒酒。在这个社交媒体和政治氛围驱使我们以非黑即白的方式、将人与问题视为敌人或盟友的时代，整合复杂度邀请我们采取一种更
expansive view of the world. It asks us to exercise humility. To see that the way we perceive things might not be the only way to perceive things. Seeing the world with greater integrative complexity has the potential to reduce animosity. And as Stephanie found, it can promote compassion to what others and to what ourselves.
广阔的视角来看待世界。它要求我们保持谦逊。看到我们看待事物的方式可能并不是看待事物的唯一方式。以更高的整合复杂度看待世界，有可能减少敌意。正如斯蒂芬妮所发现的那样，它能促进对他人以及对我们自己的同情。
In seeing the different faces of Kim and being able to hold them all simultaneously in her mind, Stephanie was able to see the multitudes within herself. She wasn't just good Stephanie or bad Stephanie. She wasn't just the helpless friend in the group of addiction or only a victim whose identity was stolen. She was Stephanie the teacher, the recovering alcoholic, the pianist, the friend, and the survivor. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Ryan Katz, Kristen Wong, Laura Correll, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick.
通过看到金的不同面孔，并能够在脑海中同时容纳所有这些面孔，斯蒂芬妮得以看到自己内心的丰富多面。她不只是那个好的斯蒂芬妮或坏的斯蒂芬妮。她不仅是深陷毒瘾群体中无助的朋友，也不仅仅是一个身份被盗用的受害者。她是身为教师的斯蒂芬妮、处于康复期的酗酒者、钢琴家、朋友和幸存者。《Hidden Brain》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、莱恩·卡茨、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·科雷尔、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。
Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Voice acting for this episode by Liza Goodstein. If you are someone you know needs help, the National Suicide Prevention Lifeline is available 24-7 at 1-800-273-TALK. That's 1-800-273-8255. Many nations have suicide prevention hotlines.
塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制作人。我是《Hidden Brain》的执行主编。本集的配音演员是丽莎·古德斯坦。如果你或你认识的人需要帮助，国家预防自杀生命线提供24小时全天候服务，电话是1-800-273-TALK。即 1-800-273-8255。许多国家都设有预防自杀热线。
So if you live outside the United States and need help, please call the one in your home country or talk to a friend, a parent or a counselor. Our unsung hero today is Jason Saldana. Jason heads up business development and content at PRX, a public media network. I've spoken to Jason many times over the past year as we launched our new production company, he has an extraordinary capacity for integrative complexity. Unsurprisingly, Jason is not only one of the smartest people I know, but one of the most empathetic. Thank you Jason.
因此，如果你居住在美国境外且需要帮助，请拨打你本国的热线，或者与朋友、父母或辅导员聊聊。我们今天的无名英雄是杰森·萨尔达尼亚。杰森负责公共媒体网络 PRX 的业务发展和内容工作。在我们成立新的制作公司期间，过去一年里我与杰森交谈过很多次，他在整合复杂度方面有着非凡的能力。毫不意外，杰森不仅是我认识的最聪明的人之一，也是最具同理心的人之一。谢谢你，杰森。
If you liked this episode, if our work has been meaningful to you, please consider supporting us. You can help by going to support.hiddenbrain.org. Every time we see someone stepping up to help, it gives us a little boost. Again, that support.hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你喜欢这一集，如果我们的工作对你意义重大，请考虑支持我们。你可以通过访问 support.hiddenbrain.org 来提供帮助。每当我们看到有人挺身而出给予帮助，都会给我们带来莫大的鼓舞。再次重申，网址是 support.hiddenbrain.org。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。再见。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。